[Musique]
c'est la fin idéale
j'ai encore trois au journal pour les
nouvelles j'espère qu'elles seront
sociaux tels voyages grande portable n'a
pas si mal surtout si des petits comera
le dragon et le petit écho de la forêt
c'est très heureux s'est déroulé il y à
toutes les informations à chaque
nouvelle édition on n'a jamais de
déception ça vous le découvrirez dans le
sud et co dauphin
[Musique]
[Rires]
voyons voyons veilhan quels sont les ou
hausses alors écoutez cherté des fans la
cigogne est de retour au haut en bas
c'est une nouvelle une nouvelle
sensationnelle
enfin arrivé comme je suis heureuse mais
heureuse aux iep
même chez les ihm mon cher petit zip zip
ou des devis pied de retour
j pour les jolies si si enfin au delà si
grave
appelez-moi del tout coup abel ton corps
du sidérant vous n'avez pas changé on
enverra daverat au pardon adel
si je change ma love dont demande belle
adèle n ont fait qu elle s'était
réfugiée chez elle
[Musique]
q vous êtes malheureux mais pour mme
habib pour vous avez abandonné
parce qu'elle voulait refaire le tour du
monde en sens contraire
anna allongé refuge à la mano river
partie ce même mois encore vous êtes
malheureux nous je suis furieuse de la
peine ou la colère d'adèle avait
bouleversé tous nos amis people a
abandonné c'était le cas refusé de
repartir avec lui alors c'est sa force
et afin de payer peau c'est la faute des
landes à paypal taddei dépôt de mode
je suis là salut la compagnie pipo nous
note 1 parlant pleut à cause doit
abandonner adèle négatif nous savons
elle a refusé et traoré de relancer à
ton tour du monde en sens contraire
mais c'est ce que j'ai fait puisque je
suis là mais c'est vrai j'aurais vite
prévient vie d'un pauvre adèle visible
egypte partie comme l'éclair et que je
suis malheureux a dit adel
[Musique]
mais pourquoi crier vous comme ça je ne
suis pas sourde les jolies surprises
promo plus rien aux matériaux à base de
fils vous avez une surprise oui vraiment
belle adèle y quelques instants plus
tard que je suis mal ou plus en plus à
deux je suis là pippo pis pour le pigeon
manon pis pour le pigeon est reparti
faire le tour du monde en sens contraire
les gars disent j'ai changé d'avis le
pipe on que je connaisse et ne change
ait jamais d'avis oh j'ai changé le
pipeau que je connaissais était très
galant avec moi voulez-vous vous asseoir
mignonat d'elle le pipeau que je
connaissais était un homme d'esprit un
dell quand vous êtes fatigué vous savez
ce qu'on peut dire non elle est morte à
dell dell o
ça y est mise en scène ap alors mignon
pipon je vous manqués infirmatif alors
adorable petit pour nous verrons plus
jamais le job injures eux
et bien moi j'ai envie de refaire le
tour du monde en sens contraire
vous venez avec moi vaio pipeau bon
autant dire que je suis
pippo ne résista pas à la peine de la
belle adèle
ils sont repartis tous les deux elle va
être morte baden à bientôt pour une
prochaine édition du petit écho de la
forêt